my bunker Trump is taking on an official
role in her father's White House the
first daughter will now have the title
assistant to the president and she will
not be paid her previous position as an
informal adviser had raised some ethical
concerns in a statement Ivanka Trump
said that she heard the concern some
have with my advising the president and
she will be subject to all of the same
rules as other federal employees
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with more on this story Margaret good
morning good morning well it's always
been controversial when the president's
family members take on an official role
and with this White House the trump
family's influence is expanding on
Wednesday President Trump formally
awarded 35 year-old daughter Ivanka the
highest staff title of any White House
employee assistant to the president the
Chancellor of Germany is going to while
relying on family is typical for a u.s.
president hiring your daughter and
son-in-law as West Wing employees is
unprecedented
it's the perfect culmination of Women's
History Month to have all of you around
the table as an unpaid employee Ivanka
will be required to file financial
disclosures perhaps quieting concern
from senators who worried that she is
not divested from her clothing company
which both the President and councilor
Kellyanne Conway have controversially
promoted in a letter this week to the
government ethics office senators
Elizabeth Warren and Tom Carper
protested Ivanka's expanding role saying
it must be determined quote which ethics
rules apply to MS Trump and whether her
compliance with these rules will be
monitored and enforced Ivanka receives a
security clearance and secure
communications devices much like her 36
year old husband Jared Kushner who
serves as a senior advisor they have a
you know exceedingly great amount of
influence in the White House
Annina McBride chief of staff to Laura
Bush says separating the family's
personal business from the government
will be key to making this work the
lines are certainly blurred there's no
question about it another open question
is whether Ivanka's personal interests
will influence her father's politics and
prevent him from carrying out
nearly 30 percent funding cut to the
State Department which runs programs of
interest to her like gender equality and
women's rights we must continue to fight
injustice in all ifs forums
First Lady Melania Trump visited that
department on Wednesday something that
the president has not yet done to honor
women humanitarians who benefit from the
u.s. diplomatic support one of the
activists honored by mrs. Trump
yesterday was from Syria and another
from Yemen Norah
neither would likely have been even
allowed into the country if US courts
had not suspended the president's travel
ban that's fascinating Margaret thank
you so much interesting that some of
those women would not have been able to
been honored if the travel ban was in
effect one of the ironies of times we
live in
absolutely yeah a different ballgame
it's a different ballgame yeah well no
doubt the Vanco will will continue to
have great influence inside the White
House